the Chris Tyson situation could become a
complete disaster for Mr Beast brand
however it may also provide some unique
benefits so let's begin by going over
the drama before explaining exactly how
this will impact the Mr Beast channel in
mid-2022 fans began to notice that Chris
Tyson was changing in the early days he
represented the quintessential Southern
gun and truck-loving dude yet beginning
in March 2022 Chris began to display
increasingly feminine traits making
tweets such as I finally got my nails
done at a nail tech additionally Chris
would highlight that his facial
appearance had changed significantly
have you ever heard of this dude before
this woman before all this happened no I
haven't how old is he uh probably like
mid late 20s okay totally normal heard
of Mr Beast and I know him the last
person on Earth yeah totally normal guy
up until now which is pretty crazy to
think about maybe I'll just find myself
when I'm 28 years old find yourself in a
straight jacket if you pull this
she accompanied another post reading
okay so in four different Customs I had
to prove I was myself because I quote
look nothing like my passport pick so
much that I'm considering updating my
passport do you see any resemblance
prompting replies such as that you went
from man to boy Chris responded by
stating nah to be honest I just really
started taking my mental health
seriously and eating better yet his
Twitter photos kept insinuating that
Chris was becoming more feminine with
this same kind of look showing up in his
Mr Beast appearances for example on the
6th of January 2023 Beast reacts
uploaded a video titled istrapped a
GoPro to a fish in which Chris dressed
in a way that prompted comments such as
Chris has been adopting more and more
traits that remind me of my grandmother
okay so some people just gonna ignore
Chris's Nails Chris had to have lost a
bet the look is getting Wilder what is
it with celebrities always dressing like
Psychopaths once they get some Fame all
of them they all dressed and they all
start dressing gay and like most
people constantly need more and more and
more attention is my guess I I'm not a
psychologist I don't understand the
whole I don't know
with wanting to just have to always have
something it's always in the news normal
normal dudes and then they go to
painting their nails and wearing dresses
is it just part of the psyop and trying
to feminize men or is it some other
psychological thing that I don't see and
it's just about attention you're just
seeing an awful lot of that right now
because that's the trend and that's the
contagion that's happening dude it's a
lot of the time with these guys so many
of them like all the big artists and
stuff they all turn so feminine I don't
know what it is response to the video
then prompted countless viral tick tocks
such as this one with 700 000 likes
stating how did Chris go from this to
this While others even made the claim
that Carl had turned him gay now this
was pretty ridiculous as Carl isn't even
that feminine and Chris had come out as
bisexual years before he and Carl had
even met the true Catalyst for Chris
Tyson's feminization instead seemed to
have come from his marriage in January
2022 Chris would post a photo with his
wife to his Instagram yet after this
that's so sad he's got a little kid
imagine my daddy was a girl now that's
that's horrible to think about as kids
we we end up seeing a lot of stuff that
goes on with our parents that we don't
understand you know seeing their
relationship Dynamics you know you might
see maybe if as you're growing up a
parent loses a job or they're struggling
with alcoholism and it's just all well
there's all kinds of adult stuff that
we're not emotionally and mentally
intellectually equipped with to
understand and this is huge though this
is really screwy the funny thing that I
was going to say is up until the age of
10 you kind of look at all of your
family members as perfect in a way you
don't even realize that your parents and
family members are going through
because it's just your life that's all
you really know and then as you grow up
you kind of start hearing the drama
because people are less careful about
talking while you're around and that
kind of stuff
this one's a pothead oh this one's
actually a goof you know right and then
you're like holy this is just
completely changing the way I looked at
everyone you know right but it's not
necessarily just because you were no I
know you were you were shielded because
your brain is wired in a certain way to
just for you to focus on play for you to
focus on yourself and your own
development and then as you get older
parts of your brain develop that
actually help you to see other people I
couldn't imagine growing up in that time
period where your brain is like a sponge
and you can learn four different
languages at the same time like yeah
there's parts of kids that are so much
smarter than adults it's literally where
your brain is being formed and if during
that time period what was being shoved
down my throat was that boys can be
girls and girls can be boys which is
just not true it's just not true it's
just not true like it's just it's just
science it's just not so I've been
trying to like think of good Arguments
for the transgender stuff and maybe hit
something with someone that'll change
their mind but I'm like a girl can't
become a boy it's as simple as that so
why would I feed into the delusion we
were fine with the gay stuff for the
longest time like whatever if you want
to go be gay go be gay because they
weren't even like shoving it down throws
as much they were just trying to get
married and go live their lives in peace
and then the t's got attached and now
that now we have to teach that boys or
girls now that just doesn't make any
sense but it's it's more than that Sonny
so now they're when it was just you know
wet gays be gazing to have the same
legal rights to get married because it
wasn't just it was just they they wanted
to live forever together as a pair and
if a man and a woman did that they could
share health insurance they had
automatic rights if God forbid the man
ends up in the hospital and he's
incapacitated the wife can make medical
decisions where a gay couple didn't have
those rights there were a lot of things
that they didn't have even though they
were in monogamous healthy lifelong
commitments so they got those rights
they never ever wanted to put books in
um in in in elementary through high
schools where teaching about gay sex or
teaching about sex in general and I'm
not talking about the function of sperm
meets egg and you know this is how it
happens yeah they're there there are
book so they're saying that
conservatives like me are you know
advocating for book Banning no one's
advocating for book Banning what they're
doing is they're trying to put books
about sexual pleasure and all different
ways and anal sex and all this crazy
and oral sex in in kids in schools
this is not this is not stuff that
children should be learning about that
was that was oh well it was abuse it was
abuse to talk to Children about adult
matters and now I'm being called The
Lunatic for saying that doesn't belong
in schools you can have your book you
can have your dirty book that's fine but
not for little kids what are you trying
I told you about how I saw my first
female body part that was a science book
there was a science book in my room
about birth about birth and on page 42
when I was like seven years old I opened
it up and there was a head coming out of
a
of a JJ right that was a that was a
Biology book which okay you're fine from
seeing that but was that was I showing
you a book about how to pleasure
yourself no no I know I'm pleasure
pleasure another young man or pleasure a
woman but that was the big deal did I
have a book about anal beads in your
room you didn't okay I'm sorry can I
speak oh my God I'm sorry to be
defensive but like you're joking around
but it's really serious and it's child
abuse to put this in little kids
heads I know I know it is to his
Instagram yet after this the family
photo stopped all together fans also
noticed that he'd removed his wedding
ring with the Rings absence correlating
perfectly with the very first post in
which he'd painted his nails Chris
confirmed the split in a post from March
2023 reading for a little over a year
now me and Katie have been separated
with this also confirming that Chris's
transformation began as soon as his
marriage came to an end Chris went from
lighting campfires and raising a family
honestly I don't even know what to think
about this because I don't I can't
wrap my head around how you go from a
totally normal truck drive and dip
chewing dude that's who he was yeah
because Nico knew him I talked to saniko
about it and he said that he was like a
totally normal dude before this that
used to shoot guns together all this
and now he's just magically a woman
how does that make any sense when you're
this influential there has to be
something underneath I just I don't buy
any of it it doesn't make sense or or
you're just so encapsulated in the woke
mind that it literally takes over yeah
because how do you go from a normal dude
to just becoming a woman it doesn't make
any sense we need Jordan Peterson in
here in the room I'm not Jordan Peterson
I'm just a normal kid and it doesn't add
up for me what happens though is we're
at least asking questions you have
people that automatically just jump to
he's just being him he's being his
authentic self and we have to love him
or we're bigots and we're transphobes
and and that that's that's a really
stupid place to jump to
automatically without asking questions
is this man healthy in the head is this
actual gender dysphoria or is this
social contagion is he escaping from
something else is he on drugs what is
going on here if I married a masculine
man and had a child with him and then he
comes home one day and says start
calling me Susie I am not going to be
happy I'm going to think there's
anything really wrong you assess in a
business when I'm in business and
there's a problem or something's going
wrong I assess where does this problem
come from and what can I do to fix the
problem so I agree with you there like
if you're in a relationship I'm dating a
girl or something and magically she just
starts thinking she's a boy all right
what are you watching some new type of
crazy videos yes what are you taking
drugs what is going on that's causing
this and then what chess move can we
move what can we do to fix this it's a
beautiful wife to now trying to be a
wife with his man buns and long nails as
the criticism continued to pile Chris
announced that he'd be taking a break
from social media I want to say there is
about roughly or traditionally has been
somewhere around one percent of the
population that has legitimate gender
dysphoria it's a real thing so we don't
want to
remember it's so easy to get mad but I
want to remember that we have to be kind
because there are some people who this
is their legitimate reality the way
somebody might have bipolar disorder or
depression or anxiety or anorexia or any
of those other mental disorders
all proven to be because I don't know
because I don't believe in chemical
clinical depression at all anymore so so
what's the difference of somebody with
PTSD and somebody who doesn't have PTSD
show show up differently yeah but PTSD
is different than clinical depression
it's part of it depression is a piece of
pts of what comes as a symptom of PTSD
yeah but 95.20 million percent very very
educated on this okay go ahead of the
current people that are saying they have
depression it's not from PTSD real PTSD
it's from them having shitty lives and
then just blaming it on depression you'd
agree with that right maybe not the
number but especially my generation why
are there like 12 year olds that are
like cutting themselves well I think I
think it's crazy to look back when I was
in eighth grade I remember there was a
transgender and it was just they were
going through transition already this
was like 2016 and there was a kid
already going through from girl to boy
at my school and it was just like normal
that's crazy to look back on I didn't
even have hair in my balls yet let alone
start transitioning to the other genders
that doesn't make any sense no sense
here's here's part of what I think the
big problem is with your whole
generation and it's my generation's
faults let me tell you the problem about
your generation Boomers and gen xers had
kids and up Society because they
all wanted their kids to have it easier
than they did and to be better so
everybody protected their children from
feelings not everybody see you can see a
helicopter appearance they were called
bulldozer parents so when you you lay
out all the problems in front of them so
they can just walk right over well
helicopter parents were similar where
you just always hovered and made sure
that your child never had to figure
things out or had a bad feeling or a bad
emotion yeah and so you know not not all
Boomers and gen xers did this thank God
so a lot of kids grew up being normal
having having the kicked out of
them a little bit by life and then they
grew up to be well-adjusted adults but
what happened is everything was you know
let's let's just use the participation
trophy example which is the big one I
always threw those out we threw them out
we talked about them and threw them out
we kept we have all of your trophies
from when you were a kid that you
actually earned I don't even keep the
non-first place ones I just tossed them
but yeah keep going so what happens
happiness and satisfaction and you know
all the the positive endorphins that go
off in your brain come from
accomplishing things and achieving
things yeah but kids never really got
that anymore they never got the
satisfaction of solving a problem by
themselves they never got the
satisfaction of you know losing one
season and you're on the wars team and
fighting harder and working harder and
then becoming you know at least getting
you know finals the next year not
everyone's gonna go have a championship
in their life you're missing you're
missing a big part of the problem too is
is phones I was just thinking about this
like phones have changed people's
Consciousness everyone's Consciousness
in real time because now tied together
you don't even have to how the did
you get around like I don't I can't even
go to the store without looking at my
map let alone how you guys had to
literally problem solve everything where
you would you just meet people and if
someone wasn't there you had to figure
it out the phone thing is a huge part
right so yes the phone and solve all the
problems for us I'm now oh okay
you you can't problem solve for basic
things and it's a distraction so every
time like I've noticed this when in
business or something and I'm coming
upon something hard or you're hitting a
little bit of writer's block as you're
writing a paragraph to get that dopamine
hit dopamine hit you just open Instagram
and then scroll through stories with
your brain shut off and it's like why
the did I just do that why couldn't
I have just sit here and just try to
work through it but your brain your your
phone reworks your brain so you always
go to it no matter what and I look at
these kids that I'm friends with and
they're all broke and they complain
about it and the first thing they do
when they wake up in the morning is they
scroll on Tick Tock Instagram reels all
this and every free second of
the day is just consuming and that's
what no wonder all these kids are broke
and depressed right that's all you do so
you're not learning you're not building
you're not being creative you're the
creative part of your brain is just
filled in by by the noise in the phone
no literally though you're not this is
why I'm doing the one week in the
bathroom I'm doing it I'm doing it a lot
of fun I'm doing I'm locking myself in
the bathroom for a whole week without so
what does that mean I just get to like
sit outside the bathroom in three days
three times a day bring you a meal yeah
bring me a meal bring me some coffee
bring me some tea I have to walk the dog
bring some hose but you won't come out
I'm not gonna come out I'm doing maybe
I'll hire a security guard so he keeps
me in there I'm not having a security
guard I do some random dude in the house
while I'm here all the time get
you're tripping to protect you we're
gonna have to find another way all right
let's keep going while there was a
possibility that Chris would make
efforts to return to his former self
he'd rather do the opposite and double
down on his family image showing up to
the Kids Choice Awards looking like this
before making the announcement that he'd
been doing I never got around to my
point it's short and sweet because there
is no real accomplishment because
parents we took these things away from
our kids and because of your point
they're staying in the phones you know
there's there's a complete lack of
actual identity on who you are what you
believe what you're producing because
you don't have thoughts anymore take on
these other identities I have to become
a social justice Warrior and create make
up a problem and fight in the street for
it even though it's not even really a
big problem there are way bigger
problems that I could be solving if I
had if I'd put my mind to it I have to
go and become a transgender non-binary
gender fluid fruitcake just to belong
somewhere and have something that's mine
a YouTuber that's what this is about
YouTuber named Sunny Fez said it best oh
what did he say that little gem words
pop up on a screen and that's your
thoughts now words pop up on their phone
and that's their thoughts people don't
have original thoughts anymore your
phone says something and that's that's
your brain now it's crazy HRT for
approximately two months which according
to a quick Google search is the medical
process for changing gender will expand
on this by stating inform consent HRT
saved my and many others lives the
hurdles GNC people have to jump through
to get life-saving gender Healthcare in
a first world country is wild to me just
let people make informed decisions about
their own bodies which received a
positive response from both Carl and Mr
Beast who wrote got you I did one more
heart than Carl because I'm oh you just
Mr Beast isn't the worst
situation imaginable can't get rid of
Chris because he'll get canceled by the
LGBT Goofs and if he keeps them people
are going to stop watching because
nobody wants to see this and then
so he just has to play along with it I
guess he's a casual situation that's
what happens when you make sure of the
biggest family-friendly family friendly
Matrix creator that there is you got to
go along with the agenda while his
co-workers Express positivity others
weren't so welcoming there goes a father
figure the kid won't ever be able to
look up to Hard Times create strong men
strong men create good times good times
create weak men and weak men create Hard
Times weak man times Chris responded to
this comment by stating this is just
more dog whistling that somehow Transit
GNC folks aren't safe around kids Tucker
begs for me to come back when I leave
for like two days to film he is so loved
and happy kids aren't born with hate
it's taught by people like you and my
child will only know that that's not
what it's about that's literally that's
not what it's about at all here you want
to say no no go ahead obviously your kid
loves you right as a a little kid still
gonna love you because they don't
understand this yet it's the
repercussions he's gonna have when he's
older and he's looking up to his father
and there's no mother I guess father
figure that's the thing there's no
father figure a child's needs masculine
and feminine guidance and so because it
used to be when I was growing up it used
to be common knowledge and common
understanding that that it was that when
there was a divorce it was a sad
situation and you know we felt bad
because we knew that the child was going
to suffer without having a strong mother
and a strong father in the home because
that balance the balance of energy and
understanding feminine and masculine
energy and ways of doing things they act
like none of that's real though we just
we live in a way it's all a fugazia with
you but the feminists the way they have
done with everything is they want to
masculinize themselves emasculate men so
they so we all have these Half Men
running around women who will never
fully be masculine trying to act
masculine men who are basically have
their balls cut off by their wives like
most women nowadays now can't be fully
masculine so it's just this squishy
thing going on and they did that and now
divorce is just you know 50 of marriages
end in divorce I don't know what what
point that is and how many many children
are in broken homes a lot you you are a
child of divorce I am in an unusual and
you are in an unusual situation in that
your father is an excellent man and has
always been there as a father to you and
a friend to me so I think my dad's proof
of Tate's point where he said to be a
good father you don't need to be there
all the time I totally agree with that
because it's not necessary if he's there
always setting a good example and every
time I was doing some dumb who who
are you threatening to call and tell
right I mean I'm gonna call Dad you can
be on a military deployment uh or any
other you know work away for work and
still be extremely strong and present in
his life so this kid though it's not
like it's a regular divorce they tried
to normalize this to make it like women
don't need men in the house we we do we
need men it's just the reality and men
need us so it doesn't make us weak it
doesn't make them weak we need each
other this kid is now going to have this
no father figure a mother and a circus
clown raising him I know I'm going to be
a great parent and so is every other
person who puts the love of their child
before everything I made this decision
because I wanted a shop as my best and
happiest self for him in a way this was
for Tucker Chris's response received
some positivity such as I'm convinced
you're an amazing father Tucker is lucky
to have you and also lucky to have all
of those who surrounded for you in his
life as well as I adore that I'm glad
you made that decision it's so much
easier to be a parental figure when
you're not struggling with dysphoria yet
he'd also receive an equal amount of
backlash you read apart your family and
took a father figure away from your son
just so you could paint your nails and
act zesty empathetic he will get torn
apart at school won't want to have
friends around his house a life full of
difference and being alone must have
missed the true though kids make fun of
you for everything when you're little
let alone if your dad's a mom that's so
sad it's never too late to start being
yourself which will save praise from Mr
Beast as well as Nolan YouTube this is
the platform that supports this oh
my God is he saying that he was never
himself all those years that he got
married under false pretenses and that
everything he did he wasn't himself I
don't buy that one bit you're trying to
tell me that before YouTube and
everything that you always felt inside
of you like you were a girl right maybe
he did it maybe there was people feel
like they're they thems it's not you
don't feel like you were they them even
when like I tried to explain this like
even when you're making music when
you're writing when you're doing
anything everything that you output is
somewhat to do with the influence of
what you've taken in in the past if you
look at letters that war that guys in
war wrote to their wives in the 1800s
they sounded so different because that
was all the literature that they took in
it sounded Shakespearean like that so
you're gonna tell me that now you're
just magically like inside of you are
they them and has nothing to do with
this outside programming that's complete
garbage the number of transgender people
right now especially the among the teen
teen children and teens is complete
social contagion total programming total
propaganda in a few years look back at
this thread and remember they were never
your friends only Yes Men cowards hope
you come out of this safe Mr Beast
responded to this with a simple opinion
irrelevant ratio to which the original
commenter would State I have 30
followers so go ahead and ratio me I'll
still rest easy knowing that I'm not a
coward who idly sits by watching my
friend his own life in some ways it was
nice to see the boys standing up for
Chris on Twitter however the situation
has already begun to change the dynamic
within the videos for example in a
recent live stream titled opening a
thousand mystery art boxes Chris would
once again dress in quite a few way yeah
well everybody participated as usual we
were at the we're at the the Bruins game
yesterday yesterday and what comes on
the screen when the dancers when the
dance the the half-time intermission
dancing thing comes up what was there
well there was like three female dancer
cheerleaders and two men why who wants
to see Men Dancing the only demographic
that would want to see Men Dancing on a
screen is gay men which there's probably
like 30 of at a Bruins game let's just
be realistic here even women don't want
to see Men Dancing because we're wired
differently yeah I don't want to see
male cheerleaders dancing I think women
would rather see women cheerleaders
dancing because I don't even get why
girls like guys like guys are gross in
that context of cheerleading I yeah I
just want to see girl cheerleaders I
don't know why we have to have male
cheerleaders I understand but like my
point is high school and Collegiate
level it's a sport where they need men
because there's but it was dudes dressed
like hoes dancing on the big screen I'm
like what nobody wants to see this even
the girls don't want to see this nobody
wants to see because like like I told
you we're not wired differently men are
different like you just wanted you like
every guy just wants to see girls
naturally and girls are naturally
repulsed by most of the guys that they
see I mean we don't even have to go down
this whole rabbit hole Yeah but even
like on Tinder and stuff there's so many
studies that show that like girls will
will swipe right like one tenth of the
time dude swipe right just because dudes
naturally are just like oh yep yep good
enough good enough good enough good
enough yeah and girls are more I mean
there's so many reasons for that that I
don't want to go into because that's a
whole video in itself and then that ties
into other things why like women
sleeping around and Men sleeping around
it's not the same you know what I'm
saying no I'm saying
but let's keep going well the energy and
Vibe didn't feel nearly as smooth as it
normally does it felt as though there
was an unaddressed elephant in the room
and therefore everybody was in their
head as opposed to being in the present
moment enjoying each other's company how
maybe everybody was simply too busy
opening packages but Chris did make
these bizarre jokes about Jimmy being
female making him incredibly
uncomfortable oh my God Jimmy look they
drew you Jimmy they drew you so well
it looks just like oh yes oh my God it's
Jimmy how did fan art this is what we
were looking for be brave be honest be
kind that is my tagline becoming even
Weir to win h I feel bad for this guy
because I like Mr Beast watching his
podcasts and stuff you know he's based
is that him no he's based Jimmy he's Mr
Beast you know he's like you know he's a
bass dude he's a g honestly but like
this stuff is just out of control I mean
it's kind of what that earlier tweet
said you're looking you're watching your
friend lose his mind and you're
supporting recording it this is like I
don't if my friends have victim
mentality around me where they say
anything isn't their fault I I
immediately go after them I'm like what
are you talking about bro like watch
some I'm sending them I'm sending them a
tape pod I'm like go watch this video
come on snap the out of it you
sound like a right now let alone
if they started calling themselves a
girl that's unbelievable I make fun of
my friends because they still work jobs
which is I know that's rude but it's
like bro I'm telling them like you're
slaving away to a corporation making
millions off of you when you could be
financially free but you scroll on
Instagram reels all day then you don't
even try to make any money well I don't
know what to do it's like you haven't
even read a business book you haven't
done anything you haven't watched a
single YouTube video on how to make
money you haven't bought a course how
the do you haven't started a
business I know I make fun of them for
this let alone supporting them
transitioning it's just
remember started to pay each other
compliments hey nice shirt thanks dude
nice shirt hey nice shirt thanks dude
nice shirt thanks nice shirt nice
shoes for the most part the live stream
was devoid of awkward moments however it
would act as fodder for another 100
million views worth of Drama and
criticism Chris likely believes that
people will slowly adapt to his new
appearance over time but is this really
going to happen well maybe it's
difficult to say as the situation is
fairly unique especially when
considering Chris's reputation and
influence however if Chris continues to
transition would it be unreasonable to
say that he could jeopardize some of the
personality traits which made him a
successful member in the first place
perhaps the opposite will happen and
he'll instead pick up new personality
traits that better resonate with the
current Mr Beast audience this was put
forward in many comments supportive of
Chris who implied that there will be
millions of queer kids who look up to
him although this doesn't necessarily
mean that it'll add any value to the
videos Mr Beast has likely cultivated a
massive LGBT audience all of whom are
already watching anyway and if we've
learned anything from Hollywood in
recent years it's that adding over the
top LGBT characters for the sake of
relatability rarely works as intended
and is often nothing more than a
distraction from the premise of the
movie or video on top of this it can be
uncomfortable and unrelatable for the
silent majority although as we have seen
a situation like Chris's does have the
potential to create an overworldly
amount of discussion which could be seen
as a benefit for the Mr Beast brand
drama is good for growth 100 that would
be an easy way
the problem is this type of situation is
probably the last thing that Mr Beast
wants to attract as he's forced to agree
with Chris's position as he has no way
of manipulating the situation without
being painted as the bad guy it's a
lose-lose situation for Mr Beast I think
Jimmy is in an inescapable situation if
he kicks out Chris canceled if he don't
his channel will die for real an
inescapable situation is a pretty good
way of describing the drama which is
also why it deserves the harsh label of
being a nightmare Jimmy has no option
but to publicly Express accept of
Chris's transition a silent or even
worse disapproval the best move would be
to have Chris say that he's stepping
away because of his mental health issues
and then all the people on the other
side would be like oh okay you need your
mental health break yada yada and then
the other side would be like all right
good now we can enjoy the videos without
this but he wouldn't do that if it
wasn't his authentic self he wants to be
on this show he wants to be the most
famous trans person you know up there
with Dylan Mulvaney it's really sad to
me I don't know what how far from
reality somebody somebody has to get
it's time to live that's Chris
be free my brother
I'm coming brother
every day countless vehicles are born
into human bodies I've never told anyone
this but I was actually born a tank but
sadly it wasn't one of our 52 genders so
what there's there's more that there's
63 genders now is someone just getting
paid to sit there and think of genders
the point I'm trying to get across is
this was a whole video I didn't even see
this one clip before this is a new joke
that I haven't even seen how crazy is
that how do you go from this to becoming
a girl that does I mean I I get
understood I understand changing your
perspective on it you know and I could
understand if he came back and he was
like you know what I'm sorry I I if that
was insensitive or some like that
but to then break up your marriage leave
your son without a father insane and and
take hormones to to insane to be less of
a man because that's all he's
accomplishing he is not being a woman he
is only becoming less of a man however
in accepting Chris's transition Jimmy
implies that this will be the new normal
within the content thus annoying a
different group of people many of whom
will never express their true feelings
and may rather simply click on fewer Mr
Bass videos if this is the case Jimmy
has no option but to accept this phase
as removing Chris from the videos in any
kind of way it could create an even more
severe media Firestorm the only clean
solution should things go south might be
for Chris to resign himself and even
then rumors and oh gender non-conforming
I got it I don't even know what that
means you mean it means you don't
identify as one of the genders isn't
there already like 10 words for that now
we need a new one no I I don't think
it's new I I swear to God there's like
45 words for not identifying as the two
genders what what is it now
I'm done with this bad press will
be unavoidable whether it be arrogance
or ignorance Chris seems oblivious to
how this whole thing might impact Jimmy
forgetting that he achieved his current
level of success of course it is he's
not thinking about anybody he didn't
think about his wife he didn't think
about his kid he didn't think about his
parents he didn't think about his
business partner he thought about
nothing but his Nails I'm giving
a hundred dollars to someone who follows
me on Instagram thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you later
[Music]